et on commence donc avec les restos du
coeur qui ont lancé leur grande collecte
annuelle ce week-end à l'entrée de 170
supermarchés et supérettes d'indre et
loire ou du loir et cher une collecte
qui s'annonce inférieur aux 185 tonnes
de l'année dernière en raison du
couvre-feu et de la fermeture des
centres commerciaux de plus de 20 mille
mètres carrés les bénévoles auront quand
même du pain sur la planche en indre et
loire ils sont mille cent parmi eux une
bonne partie de nouveau des bénévoles
d'un jour qui supplée l'absence des plus
anciens empêché par la crise sanitaire
à saint pierre des corps manon
vanoverbeke le début du week-end de
collecte a rimé avec l'intégration de
nouveaux bénévoles
c'est le cas de noemi elle a répondu à
l'appel reçu dans sa boîte mail
étudiante fait pas de mal à aller voir
les gens remplis quand ils posent des
questions j'y réponds
c'est à sousse est assez facile force et
ça vient tout seul
on nous a dit ce qu'il fallait faire
mais c'est venu très naturellement on
donne les prospectus et quand nous
ramène de la nourriture on trie suivant
première fois aussi pour marie étudiante
qui a suivi sa grand mère dans l'
aventure l'occasion de mettre à profit
sa générosité
je me suis dit si tu es une occasion
d'aider
il est étudiant qui eux aussi sont en
baisse dans le besoin il tente
moi je dis si un jour j'en ai besoin je
sais pas quand d'avoir fait
d'associations là qui vous fait en indre
et loire
les restos du coeur compte aujourd'hui
1100 bénévoles dont six ans bénévole
d'un jour
ce dernier nombre est presque deux fois
plus élevé que d'habitude
les équipes se sont démenés pour
recruter de nouveaux bras en sollicitant
faculté des entreprises locales avec la
crise sanitaire les besoins se sont
multipliés
nos bénéficiaires ont augmenté de 10% il
faut absolument qu'on trouve des
produits alimentaires pour distribuer à
nos bénéficiaires on s'attendre encore
d'ici la fin du premier semestre une
augmentation régulière du nombre de
bénéficiaires qui vont venir nous nous
voir suite au licenciement au dépôt de
bilan de l'entreprise ainsi de suite
ceux des gens qu'on va malheureusement
retrouvé aux restos du coeur et on est
prête à les aider ya aucun problème
le 16 mars marquera l'ouverture d'un
nouveau centre de l'association dans le
quartier maryse bastié et la collecte se
poursuit quant à elle jusqu'à dimanche